so what we're gonna do today is we're
gonna finish up a bit of transcription
and then I'm going to talk largely about
transcription control because it's
tremendously important that we actually
not just know how to transcribe but we
know how it's controlled and how
ultimately the appropriate messenger RNA
is sent out for a translation into
protein so transcription control is a
very important component so let me just
start with this first so these are
typical of questions and they look like
gosh I don't have enough information to
answer this question and it's basically
about what's known as the transcription
bubble which is the portion of the
double-stranded DNA where transcription
is occurring and so a transiently the
double-stranded DNA is opened up for DNA
for the RNA polymerase which remember
has inbuilt helicase activity to start
transcribing the gene so let's just say
we have given the information we might
give you is that transcription starts
here at this point on the
double-stranded DNA and what we want to
know it you to know is that you have all
the information you need to know which
of the two strands is copied have you
had a chance to think about that does
anyone want to give me a good answer to
that yes here and why is that right so
that reading things 3 prime to 5 prime
and making things 5 prime to 3 prime is
all you need to know to answer this
question so you would straightaway know
ok we're going to start somewhere here
but we're actually going to start on the
lower strand because that's the 1 3
prime to 5 prime and we're going to make
the Nutri transcript in the appropriate
direction and know what it's going to be
so if you can only read the bottom
strand in this case but watch out
because you might be reading the top
strand in the other direct in the
appropriate direction as well but what
we've told you already is where the
start site
so you're gonna know that information if
we put for example that the start site
was over here you might have different
answers to this question so the only
single EULA piece of information you
need is that you read three to five and
you make five to three then you can also
fill in the bases to know what the
transcribed sequence looks like and I
always recommend when you're filling in
bases you just write five prime to three
prime so you really are following
properly which is being read and the
direction it's being read and so if you
were asked what would you RN a secret
messenger RNA sequence would be you'd
get it right and here I just have a few
questions that will help highlight the
differences between the transcription
process and the replication process so
can you guys just read each of these and
see whether they look like rules that
apply to transcription or they're things
that are not true about transcription so
just give you one second to think about
that
who okay who would like to give me an
answer someone over in this part of the
room I haven't haven't heard as much for
yes DNA okay so the correct answer is
that we only transcribe about 1.5
percent of the genomic DNA
we're not transcribing the whole thing
we're only transcribing the bits that we
need to make proteins so the correct
answer is C because we don't make a copy
of the whole of genomic DNA but these
are alright we have a different set of
nucleotides or rather a difference in
one of the nucleotide triphosphate
building blocks remember that RNA
polymerase does not require a primer
that was a complication when we looked
at replication because we had to paste
in primers made often by the prime ace
RNA primase our RNA polymerase is much
cleverer than DNA polymerase because it
has the polymerase activity it has the
helicase activity there isn't needed a
topoisomerase
were only opening a little bit of the
double-stranded to copy I'll show you a
movie in a second and it also has a
three prime exonuclease which means that
RNA is able to do its own proofreading
just like the DNA polymerase so the
error rate is kind of similar to the
error rate with the exonuclease activity
for DNA so that's about 1 in 10 to the 5
to 10 to the 6 now I'm gonna talk in a
minute there's not the same sort of
cadre of repair enzymes that we have for
DNA and that's a curious thing until you
start thinking about what the what the
reality is so let me try to lead you to
my thinking so we're genomic DNA that's
the copy of the DNA that's in the
nucleus that has to stay good so if
there's any mistakes we need them
cleaned up because otherwise when we
replicate that a set of all of the
double-stranded DNA there will be an
error in the progeny the daughter cells
for transcribing RNA an error rate of
about one in ten to the five versus what
to one in ten to the six is just fine
that piece of RNA ends up after a few of
the processing steps that I'll describe
to you ends up leaving the nucleus to be
made into proteins and it's not such a
bad thing if you have a little bit more
error in that RNA why is that over here
or up there actually yeah right right so
if you have a bit of an error maybe you
make a new protein but it's not
full-length or the protein you make
isn't perfect it's okay because there'll
be other transcripts that are correct
and then after you've done making the
protein then you don't then you can just
you're just going to destroy that RNA
because it has a transient life time
because of the structure of the RNA and
the nucleases that chew up the RNA
so this is an acceptable error rate for
RNA polymerase remember it's not an
acceptable error rate to have in your
genome okay it's just too big
any questions about that does that all
make sense okay all right so now we want
to talk about transcription control but
before I do that I do want to very
quickly show you something because I
feel like it really caps off the
transcription part and I just want I'm
gonna show you only about a minute of
this with respect to starting but now
the whole complex the RNA polymerase is
just screeching through the DNA making
messenger RNA and you're only um
unravelling just a little bit of DNA
around that transcription bubble so you
wouldn't need the topoisomerase in this
case
[Music]
you are
out of the cold place that gets
[Music]
when I hear that music I'm just sort of
waiting for the whole thing to crash
somewhere but who would know right
alright so at the beginning of that
animation a few things were highlighted
where there's the double-stranded DNA
and a collection of entities starts
clustering around where the reading is
going to take place so this thin black
strand is the double-stranded DNA so
some of the entities accumulate quite
close to the start site there is a
section of DNA known as a tata box that
we spoke about in the lot at the very
end of the last lecture but there are a
number of transcription factors that are
quite important but then you might also
if you go back and look at that
animation there are sections of DNA that
are at quite a distance that also help
really regulate and promote
transcription so many factors regulate
whether transcription occurs first of
all is there a promoter site right near
where we need to start that causes a
fair amount of collecting of complex
components but then there may be other
things at a distance so the promoter
region might be located quite near the
transcription start site but then there
are also enhancers that can be located
at quite a big distance away from the
start site that also play a role why do
we need this much control because we
don't need making the RNA for every
protein all at the same time certain
times in cell cycle you'll see I only
need to make one protein or a different
protein so we need all of this control
to decide when transcription occurs when
do we need to make the messenger RNA to
make our favorite new protein that needs
to be made and you'll learn a lot in
signal transduction and cell cycle where
we really show you how a lot of the
housekeeping genes are all fine the
proteins are all there but the descent
stage we need to make more of a
particular protein and that's when the
transcription control comes into play
and you'll commonly hear about
is called transcription factors knows
maybe the proteins for example that
regulates that transcription should
start in other cases there may be times
when transcription is turned down so we
have things that activate so we start
transcription we make that happen or
others that repress so they turn down
transcription so it's all about when
when you need to start which is
controlled by external factors acting on
the double-stranded DNA to send the
transcription complex making the new
entity alright does that make sense we
can't have a dysregulated system or if
we do then we have problems with for
example plural proliferation of cells
all right so what I want to talk about
are the key things that regulate
transcription and the key things that we
do to the messenger that's been made so
what you're seeing here on this slide is
just sort of where we are in the process
we've seen replication we're now at the
transcription step but there are many
steps to go in eukaryotes before that
transcript can leave the nucleus alright
and I want you to remember the
difference between eukaryotic and
prokaryotic cells this was just a
picture we saw very early on prokaryotic
cells like bacteria do not have a
nucleus they have an area called a
nucleolus but they don't have a discreet
membrane encased organelle where the
processes of replication and
transcription occur in contrast in
eukaryotes there is a discrete area of
the cell the nucleus that includes all
the machinery for replication and
transcription and it also includes the
machinery that takes a messenger a pre
messenger RNA
into a mature RNA whoops messenger RNA
that can leave the nucleus if you send
that pre messenger out there it's gonna
have a lot of stuff wrong with it it's
not going to be ready to face the
outside of the nucleus it's gonna be
readily degraded it's not going to have
the full information so I want to talk
to you about the processes that are put
in place for this conversion from the
priya messenger RNA to the messenger RA
which we don't have to think about in
prokaryotes the small organisms without
organelles all right all right so and
this is the sort of the the foundation
of translation transcriptional control
alright so we've talked about promoters
and enhancers those happen early that's
all about making the pre messenger RNA
but now we have to discuss some aspects
that are also critical for making the
the initial pre messenger RNA and that's
chromatin remodelers or chromatin
remodelling because in order to
transcribe anything there's a lot of
ground to cover with respects to
unwrapping the chromatin the chromosomes
because they're all packed up in such a
way then you can't possibly do any
transcription there because they're too
tightly packed in order to be accessible
for the transcription machinery to
tackle it so I show you parts of that
machinery up here these are the
nucleosomes the make up chromatin which
makes up the chromosomes and in order
for you to even be able to
transcribing you have to unravel that
part that can't those complex structures
that are tightly wrapped up you've got
an axe make the double stranded DNA
accessible otherwise you can't break
into it so there are two things that
also contribute to allowing
transcription and that is those occur
both at the DNA level and the histone
level and talk about the histone level
changes first do I want you to recall
that histones are proteins that I have a
lot of positive charge by virtue of the
fact that they include two of the
positively charged amino acids arginine
and lysine and if you're curious about
those structures you can go look back at
the table of the amino acids and see
that those guys are always positively
charged the reason we use histones to
wrap as the sort of the core of the
nucleosome structure is they're very
positively charged and they neutralize
the dense negative charge of the nucleic
acid otherwise we couldn't pack it up as
tightly as we do so changes that occur
at the histone level in order and their
remodeling of the chromatin in order to
promote transcription his modification
oftentimes to neutralize those charges
so the one most obvious one I'll show
you and then there are others where you
sort of add methyl groups that sort of
dampen down the charge where I
understood show you the very obvious one
so let's just look at lysine in a
protein that looks like this that is a
terrible drawing it has a positive
charge four bonds to nitrogen in order
to neutralize that charge there enzymes
that isolate or transfer an acyl group
to turn this positively charged a mean
into a neutral
II might let me draw that side chain
because I think it makes much more sense
to understand it this particular thing
from a chemical perspective so we still
have the N but it is now part of an
amide so the charge has been neutralized
on on nitrogen if the charge is
neutralized on the positively charged
residues in the histones the DNA will be
encouraged to kind of unravel from those
it makes good chemical sense that that's
a good way to start unpackaging DNA okay
the other modification occurs at the DNA
level and it's methylation of cytosine a
little harder to explain from a chemical
sense but up there in the corner of this
slide I've shown you these the pictures
so methylation on cytosine would look
like this this encourages stabilization
of the chromatin so what would that do
to transcription if I've stabilized the
chromatin it represses it it turns it
down so these are pairs of changes that
act in opposite direction so we down
regulate transcription okay so DNA
methylation causes the chromatin to be a
bit more compact more stable it's much
harder to unravel the DNA it's obviously
then harder to start transcription in
contrast modification of the histone
proteins to neutralize their charges
destabilizes and up regulates
transcription because it's allowing us
to open up the nucleosomes in order to
make the DNA available so that all makes
sense so we have to
counterbalances that play in each
direction okay all right
so that's chromatin remodeling the next
two transformations I'll show you may
certainly look fairly complicated but
I'm going to describe them to you and
show you what the changes are and how
they would contribute to stabilizing the
transcript and finishing the transcript
up to make it ready to leave the nucleus
to go out to the cytoplasm where the
machinery to translate proteins is
because you want to remember the
ribosomes that we're going to use on
Friday aren't in the nucleus they're in
the cytoplasm so there is a variety of
events there's what's known as 5 prime
cappings
so that is going to be a change let's
just say this goes down this is the base
remember 1 2 3 prime 5 prime it's
something that's happening to this end
of the messenger RNA that stabilizes it
so spy prime crapping is important for
one end and then the other end there is
poly a dental a tion of the 3 prime end
ok so let's just look at these one at a
time and let me convince you that they
are important changes in the transcript
that will preserve its identity and in
fact give it a little bit more
information because indeed the 5 prime
capping modification actually is a
signal later on when the transcript
leaves the nucleus for protein
translation but in general both of these
changes mechanically protects the ends
the part of the gene that you're going
to want to translate they basically
leave that piece of gene in the middle
where it's not going to be nibbled up
it's not going to be degraded because
the biggest threat to the messenger RNA
are things known as EXO nucleases
exonucleases chew down nucleic acids
from the two ends alright so let's look
first and it's kind of wild and crazy
chemistry the the five prime capping and
then we'll discuss the other two and
then I will finish these types of
changes with splicing which is really
cool and extremely important the
transcript the pre messenger RNA has to
go through all of these steps before
it's ready for nuclear export so in five
prime capping you have this strand of
pre messenger RNA everything looks
pretty happy it's all in one piece but
the first thing that happens is three
phosphates are added to that five prime
age group so that's the start of this
process and this process actually
happens while you're still transcribing
the double-stranded DNA it's actually
already going on as soon as that
component of the newly transcribed pre
messenger RNA is made things start
happening at the five prime end to
protect it at that stage then once those
three phosphates are put on there
another nuclear base is sort of added
backwards so there's a couple of
functions this all looks pretty strange
the rest of this still looks quite good
it looks fairly intact but then the next
thing that happens is that the the
guanine that's here is methyl you do not
have to remember this stuff I couldn't
remember it I just want to show you how
weird and different
the five prime end looks it doesn't look
like a strand of RNA so the guanine is
methylated and then a couple of the
ribose also ribose is those sugars that
have an O h usually at two prime get
methylated so we
created this tie entire thing of the
five prime end known as the five prime
cap that looks nothing like regular
messenger RNA and that protects that end
of the messenger and makes it safe from
a variety of insults and so let's take a
look why does it happen so the first
thing is it stops nucleus activity
because the nucleus could look at it and
go how do you recognize any of this
happy mess I'm not gonna chop down this
component it's too foreign to me so
that's the primary thing but then it's
actually quite important for regulation
of when that messenger needs to leave
the nucleus there are proteins involved
in helping export the messenger RNA when
it's ready from the nucleus so that's
it's an important signal or recognition
element it marks this thing as a
messenger RNA that's going to be
important in translation it gives it an
identity and then finally it can
actually in the next step promote
translation so all of these things are
useful so we do a number of these
unusual transformations but they all
have a reason and they all carried out
in the nucleus purposed to protect the 5
prime cap of the messenger and actually
make it ready for its next tasks all
right the next thing that happens is
what's known as polyadenylation
so here's it this would be the 5 prime
cap in the middle would be your gene
that you're going to transcribe but at
the other end there's an enzyme that
puts on a lot of adenine nucleotides and
basically adds to the other end a lot of
a's and when i say a lot you know it's
honey it can be hundreds and it just
promiscuously keeps on a dental aiding
and now what's this bit for once again
it protects from exonuclease activity
from the other end of the strand because
if you have exonuclease activity you
might start munching away at these a's
but these aren't the important parts of
the messenger right these are just
add-ons it's kind of a buffer it's like
something to do while you're waiting
you know chew up some aids but you're
not messing up the messenger RNA that
you need at the end so it's sort of
adding some dummy sequence that will be
handy there it contributes to stability
the tails shortened over time but it's
non-coding so that's okay and actually
though when the tail is short enough the
poly add and the entail kind of acts as
a bit of a timer because once the tail
gets short you start chewing into the
transcript and you basically end up with
the degradation of the transcript but it
gives you time in the cytoplasm for the
gene to be translated into protein does
that all make sense so it's just it's
basically like an egg timer just
watching watching back back back
okay this transcript has been out here
long enough we've made all the protein
we need now we're gonna chew up the
coding part and then finally it's
actually a good marker again for leaving
the nucleus and then finally it's kind
of a cool tool for technology because
there's a lot of interest I'm gonna go
up here in characterizing what's known
as the transcriptome okay it's all well
and good to characterize the genome but
it's a lot of work 3.2 billion base
pairs and only a part of it a tiny part
of it the parts are the genes that
encode the proteins so what you'd really
want to know if you want to analyze the
genes that are going to become the
proteins or maybe look for defects is
look at the things that are going to be
transcribed so you can use the fact that
there is this poly a tail on the G on
the transcripts that are going to leave
the nucleus with something that will
pull them out of the mix what would I
use let's say I've got resin bead
polystyrene or some favorable polymer
and I can attach covalently
nucleic acids to that bead what would I
add there to fish this law out
yeah up here yeah yep a lot of cheese so
I'm gonna make this I'm gonna put on a
bunch of T's and I can do this
LOX this is done very very commonly and
then I'm just going to fish out
everything that is part of the
transcriptome not the genome so I've got
a much smaller job then to find out
errors in the genes that encode the
proteins than if I was gonna start with
the entire genome it's a pretty cool
tool and later on we're gonna see how
this can be used it's actually used in
concert with an interesting enzyme that
comes from viruses called reverse
transcriptase but that's a story for a
later day but it is kind of a cool story
now the last thing that we do in the
nucleus is arguably the most important
and that is splicing okay so this is
alright once again this is a picture
with a lot of moving parts but I want to
convey to you the point of splicing as
opposed to you knowing all the little
details it was noticed for a long time
that the G the the messenger didn't
always correspond to the original
transcript and this is the case in
eukaryotes not in bacteria but that
there was quite a lot of processing done
not just to cap the ends but by cutting
out chunks of the transcript
some removal of segments of the
transcript and a lot of the seminal work
was done by Phillip sharp who's a member
of our faculty in the biology department
so we're very proud of this this was
actually the the topic of a Nobel Prize
in the 90s and so what was noticed is
that if you had a gene and let's just
put it here 5 prime to 3 prime and I'm
gonna name these and then I'll explain
to you what they are these would be
called exons these would be called
introns and this is another exon
outside-inside that's the way to
remember them and what happens in
splicing is that the introns are chopped
out ok so your gene then ends up being
if this is exon 1 an exon 2 not
represented by this entire thing but
eliminating that middle component and
remember all the time we have the
Catlett 5 we have the poly a tail
I had infinitum the three prime ends so
we've just changed the middle and it was
recognized through bioinformatics
analysis the basically noticed the
pieces that were chopped out and the
pieces that ended up being joined and
protein splicing occurs as a sequence of
events that ends you up with the protein
being spliced together through a series
of rearrangements that occur on the
structure of the nuclear messenger RNA
so there's an internal rearrangement a
new phosphate is made and then there's
another rearrangement where there's a
new bond made between
one end of the of the pre-messenger RNA
and the other mess burn and at the pre
messenger RNA to give you the spliced
the exon rejoined ready to be read in
translation now why is this so important
so I want to go here to a few numbers
that I think are very pertinent which I
had to drill my colleagues for because I
didn't know all the numbers so when the
genome was sequenced we were sort of a
bit stunned because the number of coding
things that are genes that are going to
be turned into proteins was much smaller
than we anticipated for manners about
it's currently in about 20,000 genes
that's 20,000 sort of mature transcripts
that could make proteins fly not much
smaller arguably they're pretty smart
16,000 yeast 6000 a bacteria 4,000
there doesn't seem to be enough of a
difference but a huge amount of
diversity is introduced into the
transcripts by different splicing events
because if you make one transcript that
would count as one gene but if there's a
lot of opportunities for different
splicing activity you can piece together
new transcripts that will encode
proteins differently and I think this
this next slide will show you an example
of a transcript that has several
different introns and exons so you can
see here across there's a blue green red
another blue and an orange exon but
depending on which pieces are spliced
out we'll have different proteins end up
so it could be a way for example you
know to think of a practical use to have
a protein that is either secreted as a
soluble protein or left in the membrane
with a membrane Association domain or
left in the cytoplasm but it has no way
to be secreted so it could be a way to
make three proteins that are in
completely different places of a cell or
have different functions it's also very
important in tissues because we splice
proteins diff
in muscle or liver or hearts to achieve
different outcomes in the proteins that
we make so basically it's a source of
huge diversity and it gives us the
genetic diversity that means this 20,000
can be a much bigger number and then
with the post translational
modifications I talked about when I cut
back when we come back later on you'll
see we've got lots of ways to diversify
that 20,000 that mean these aren't
literal numbers they're quite buried but
you what you want to remember is ecoli
doesn't do splicing there's no
opportunity there it's much more limited
in yeast so is the post translational
modification so these numbers settle out
quite differently from what they look
like by looking directly at those
numbers and I wanted to give you an
example you don't have this in your
slides but I was thinking about it the
other day a colleague of mine professor
penta Lutie in chemistry works on trying
to reprogram genes to overcome a disease
known as Duchenne muscular dystrophy
it's another genetic disorder it's
excellent
so it's much more serious in males than
in females because if you only have one
bad copy of the gene you can do okay
with this disease whereas in the male
you'd only have it you'd only have the
component of the gene that's on the X
chromosome so and it's a defect in RNA
splicing so directly there so let me so
this is a biopsy of muscle where red
would be good muscle cells whereas the
white would be lipid fat cells and they
actually weaken the integrity of the
muscle because the muscle doesn't
develop to have all the the well-defined
muscle cells that are important for
muscle tensile strength and
contractility and everything else that
muscles do and it's all related to a
protein known as dystrophin which is a
huge protein and it's a critical
structural protein that's important to
maintain the cellular membranes within
the muscle cells so if dystrophy is no
good the cell membrane integrity is no
good
and you just end up with losing the
muscle cells a cost of replacing them
with fat cells in the muscle and here's
a really amazing number the gene that
encodes dystrophin has 79 excellence so
you can picture the opportunities for
things to go wrong and it's actually a
defect in the place where the splicing
happens so a splicing event cannot
happen and so the protein at the end of
the day is not is not good so there's a
lot of efforts going on antisense
efforts and even other gene therapy
efforts and also nowadays there's
obviously a large focus on CRISPR base
gene editing but remember this is a
serious debilitating disease of all
muscle tissue it starts to be noticed
when babies are toddlers because that's
really when they start to engage muscle
strength so around the age of four it's
actually noticed and then the life
expectancy is in the sort of 30 to 40
years old range but it's also a terrible
lifestyle because the lungs don't work
so many organs don't so many things rely
on muscle strings okay good alright so I
believe that's the end of that but I
want to give you an introduction to
translation so you'll see what we have
in store for Friday and just get you
back to this picture we've done
everything we need we've done all the
processing we're here and then the Tran
the mature messenger RNA can finally
leave the nucleus to be ready for
translation and the cap bite there's a
complex that binds the five prime cap
that's tasked with helping export that
transcript from the messenger RNA from
the will through the nuclear pore which
is a fairly large opening outside into
the cytoplasm and I want to show you one
other thing and I hope I can get this
reliably because with this I'm going to
actually show you some of the moving
parts there's a little thing on the side
bar now called a short translation
and so what you're seeing here the black
line is the messenger RNA okay so that's
the thing that's finally out there in
the cytoplasm ready the pale green and
yellow are the two components of the
ribosome which is a soluble organelle
that assembles on the double-stranded
DNA based on a few cues the dark blue
components are transfer RNAs that bring
in new amino acids and what you see
threading out here is a new protein
strand that is being translated this
particular translation is to make a
protein that becomes membrane bound and
secreted so I'm not gonna go further
than that but there's a lot of those
light blue proteins that are actually
helping escort the transfer RNAs to
where they're needed to continue
building the proteins so we've seen the
messenger we'll learn more about the
ribosome and we'll learn about the
transfer RNAs and you can also watch
this to your heart's content
I just find it just a useful simple
cartoon that tells us a lot so what I
really want to encourage you to do is
read this section fourteen point five
because the next parts will make a great
deal more sense so what I want to do
though now is first of all start with
describing the players in translation
and just the way we did for replication
we're going to systematically ascribe
the importance to each of these players
so what you see there are molecular
players and there are key steps so the
molecular players are shown here so so
far we've focused very strongly on the
messenger RNA you know all about that
you know where it's from
you know it's stable in the cytoplasm
for a while you know it's got signals
that tell the complexes where to join go
down then we need transfer RNAs and
amino acids and we need the ribosomes
and ribosomes are made of a composite of
nucleic acid and protein wrapped
together there's quite a big difference
in prokaryotic and you
periodic ribosomes and I'll mention that
when we get to it but I want to focus
for a few moments first of all on the
landmarks that got us to finally in 2009
the structure of the ribosome is a cool
development for everyone but also where
we came from in the 60s when Crick and
Brenner finally cracked the genetic code
and found out that three bases on that
messenger RNA will encode each new amino
acid that gets put into your protein
sequence I want to introduce you to the
the transfer RNAs that are really the
most important element to start thinking
about and you can call these guys the
decoders because what the transfer RNA
does is it can carry an amino acid on
one end of its nucleic acid but on one
of the other loops within the transfer
RNA is what's known as an anticodon the
recognizes a codon in the messenger RNA
and basically prescribes what amino
acids get put in so it was always a
wonder how you went from the nucleic
acid world to the protein world the
answer is you use a nucleic acid that
you can load with an amino acid but it
can also recognize the messenger RNA the
codes for the protein sequence and
that's why they like to think of them as
decoders but what this picture of them
in jessenia the RNA shows you is the
beautiful structure of RNA where at one
end is where an amino acid would be
attached there's this cool kind of
cloverleaf structure and then at the
other end is the anticodon loop that
will actually recognize your messenger
RNA so I'm gonna stop now but what I
really I really want to encourage you
just skim through that small section
it'll make a lot more sense on Friday
protein trend I've been waiting to talk
to you about protein translations
since we started this class but it'll
make it make a lot more sense and
there's some super cool initiatives in
chemical biology now where people have
been able to completely hijack protein
translation and not put in just 20
regular boring amino acids but actually
put in all kinds of other amino acids so
we understand this system well enough to
manipulate it and this really harkens to
the Fineman quotes if you can build it
you can understand it that's the level
to which we understand translation
nowadays that's it for today
you